Well, I hate buzzwords,...
...but I think matching people, planets, and profits...
...is not a bad one if you have to have one.
And I think that, you know, I think first of all, people who create businesses,...
...you have to ask, you know, "What are they doing?" What they're doing is...
...trying to make a difference to people's lives.
And if you make a difference, a positive difference to people's lives,...
...you're gonna have a successful business.
You know, about business, it should not be just about the shareholders...
...and should not be just about the bottom line.
And if you're running a business, you should be making a difference to people...
...and making a difference to the world.
And that difference to the world, you know, should be in these many different areas,...
...you know, you can possibly cope with.
There's no question that, you know, trying to work towards a cleaner world...
...should be on the list. I think of every, you know, chief executive, chairman, president's,...
...a business's agenda.